طلب متظاهرون اردنيون بكسر الحصار المفروض
على غزه وذلك خلال مسيره انطلقت من امام
المسجد الحسيني في وسط العاصمات الاردنيه
تحت عنوان حصار غزه امريكي بايد عربيه
وشدد المتظاهرون الذين يواصلون احتجاجاتهم
في الاردن نصره لقطاع غزه رغم الاحوال
الجويه الصعبه شددوا على ضروره ادخال
المساعدات الغذائيه والطبيه الى اهل غزه
الذين يتعرضون لحرب اباده جماعيه ومضى على
معاناتهم
ي هذه الصور مباشره من وسط عمان وهذه
التظاهرات بعد صلاه الجمعه والشعارات التي
ترفع تاييدا
لقطاع غزه والشعب الفلسطيني ونصره
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه في غزه وتنديدا
بجرائم الاحتلال والحصار المطبق على
القطاع من محيط المسجد الحسيني وسط عمان
تحديدا معنا مدير مكتب الجزيره حسن شوبكي
حسن ضعنا في هذا الزخم وهذا الحراك
الاسبوعي والتظاهرات الداعمه
للقطاع الكيان من 100 سنه فالحرب
اليوم سلمى المظاهرات مستمره وهي يعني في
كل المحافظات الاردنيه وفي العاصمه عمان
وال المطلب الرئيسي اكسر الحصار مظاهره
اليوم من امام المسجدين وسط العاصمه عمان
كما تشاهدون حصار غزه هذا عنوانها حصار
غزه امريكي بايد عربيه وهنالك يعني
مطالبات من الشارع الاردني بكسر هذا
الحصار وادخال المساعدات الغذائيه والطبيه
الى القطاع المحاصر وهنالك نحو 1000 طبيب
اردني يتبعون لنقابه الاطباء الاردنيه
يعني قدموا طلبا الى منظمه الصحه العالميه
من اجل للدخول الى قطاع غزه ومسانده اهل
القطاع الذين يتعرضون لحرب اباده جماعيه
على ايدي قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي هنالك يعني تدحرج في التازيم
ما بين الاردن واسرائيل على المستوى
الرسمي بالامس شهدنا اخبارا وانباء
اسرائيليه تم سحب سحبها بعد ساعات وتقول
ان اسرائيل
تدرس يعني عدم تجديد اتفاقيه المياه مع
الاردن
وه الاتفاقيه التي جت بعد اتفاقيه وادي
عرب في عام
1994 و هذه المياه ينظر اليها الشارع
الاردني بانها اسرائيل بسيطرته على المياه
وسرقه المياه تعطي بقدر و يعني وتغبيش
ان اسرائيل تتحدى العالم علانيه قال ذلك
في مجلس الامن في جلسه عن غزه والشرق
الاوسط وقال ان اسرائيل تتحدى العالم
علانيه وان مجلس الامن لم يتقدم ولم يطلب
وقف اطلاق النار وان كل الجهود
الدبلوماسيه التي بذلت لم تتمكن من وقف
اطلاق النار ولا من مسانده اهل غزه الذين
يتعرضون الى حمله اباده بالفعل جماعيه
وشرسه ويقودها الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
اسرائيلي دون ان يقف المجتمع الدولي في
مواجهه ذلك الاستياء من تصريحات الصفدي
اسرائيليا تم التعبير عنه باكثر من طريقه
وهنالك
مطالبات بالشارع الاردني ان يرفع الاردن
ايضا من مستوى الضغط الدبلوماسي والسياسي
على اسرائيل التي يعني ما زالت تخوض هذه
الحرب وهذا العدوان منذ نحو 112 يوما وال
المطالبات كما قلت لك سلم اليوم ان هذا
الحصار امريكي وبايدي عربيه والمطالبات
فتح معب رفح وهنا اريد ان يعني ربما يعني
بمتابعتك لهذه المسيرات التي تنظم اسبوعيا
واكثر من اسبوعيا في بعض الاحيان كيف
تبدلت
الشعارات حسن يا مصري يا ابن الن فوق فوق
اخ الشعارات طبعا سلمى تتبدل من وقت لاخر
بحسب التطورات التي تجري في قطاع غزه
الملتقى الوطني لدعم المقاومه وحمايه
الوطن والذي يضم احزاب معارضه اسلاميه
ويسار هذا والقوميه هذا هذا الملتقى كل من
وقت الى اخر يركز على الاحداث التي يعني
تتطور بشكل متدحرج في قطاع غزه خلال هذا
الاسبوع
شهدنا تظاهرات في محيط السفاره المصريه
للمطالبه بفتح معبد رفع طعا الشارع
الاردني والمعارضه والمتظاهرون يعتقدون ان
الاغلاق الذي يعني هو لمعبر ربح هو يتم
يعني من طرف مصري وايضا هنالك عرقله
اسرائيليه يعني هم يعني يعني يحملون
المسؤوليه للجهتين
سواء قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي التي تعرقل
دخول المساعدات عبر المعبر وكذلك ايضا
يطالبون مصر بان تفتح المعبر وان تتحمل
اسرائيل مسؤولياتها عن جرائمها هذه
الشعارات سلمى تتغير وتتبدل وفقا ل
حاله قطاع طا غزا والمطالبه الرئيسيه
اليوم هي اكسروا الحصار لان شكرا حسن
الشوبكي مديره مكتبنا من وسط عمان شكرا
لكم